les premiers vaccinés de la communauté
droitier dans les territoires du
nord-ouest sont soulagés leur village
accessible seulement par avion au pas
route de glace est isolé du reste du
monde les risques de transmission de la
coved 19 sont donc faibles mais une
éclosion ici pourrait avoir des
conséquences très graves en raison du
manque d'infrastructures et des maisons
multigénérationnel mais femmes les mêmes
ici loin de tout la pandémie fait peur
la travailleuse la santé madeleine jouda
se rencontrent régulièrement des
patients qui doivent sortir de la
communauté elle a peur d'attraper le
virus il le transmettre à sa mère qui
avait avec elle ou equity est l'une des
seize collectivités à recevoir une
équipe de vaccination cette semaine dans
les territoires du nord-ouest
c'est dur on décrit cette organisation
parce que il ya plusieurs aspects du
plan de vaccination où il faut qu'on se
coordonnent chaque petite pièce avec
tous les autres même s'il est plus
facile à transporter que le vaccin de
pfizer usa et ailleurs au pays
celui de modern art reste très complexe
à distribuer les directives sur les
températures d'entreposage doivent être
suivies à la lettre pour éviter le
gaspillage
ça demande une planification assez
précise le moment qu'on décide de sortir
de vaccin n'étant pas john ambiante
qu'on a assez de gens pour vacciner à ce
défi s'ajoute la méfiance face au vaccin
bien présent dans les communautés une
craintes nourries par la désinformation
qui circule sur les médias sociaux mais
aussi par les mauvaises expériences
vécues par les autochtones dans le
système de santé de testeurs plusieurs
refusent d'être les premiers à recevoir
le vaccin dit elle la solution pour les
autorités sanitaires la sensibilisation
mais surtout la collaboration avec les
leaders des communautés savoir un chaume
à pied bot dad
ako dieu mes vidéos cultes feu dame sady
symboliques comme le chef chantre board
qui a choisi de se faire vacciner pour
montrer l'exemple
les autorités sanitaires des territoires
du nord-ouest du nunavut et du qu'on
espère vacciner 75 % de leur population
d'ici la fin mars
ici mario de ciccio radio canada il ya
l'unef